[Music]
it was a massive weight off my shoulders
more in the sense of
i i could be transparent with my close
family and friends and that to be
completely honest was not easy and you
know certain people in my life are not
there anymore because of this and
certain people in my life i think our
relationship has gotten stronger i still
to this day
get messages from people all over the
world all different ages
explaining to me what my story has meant
to them 911 lone star what an incredible
show tk has become a fan favorite
welcome home tk
[Music]
i can only imagine the amount of
messages that you get from people saying
i feel seen it's just unbelievable man
and it's every single day i hear from
somebody new you know reaching out and
telling us what the show means to them
and what tk means to them i think the
biggest one that i could sort of think
of it always stands out is i sort of
call him my real-life tk he's a queer
firefighter from canada he was very much
closeted did not feel safe and
comfortable telling his peers he saw
that tk became a paramedic and it
inspired him to become a paramedic so
now he moved from a rural town in canada
to vancouver where now he's fully
himself he's out to his firehouse and
now he's on the verge of going to
medical school and wants to become a
doctor so it's truly changing people's
lives and on such a deeper level than
just being you know a character on a tv
show it's it's really really really
unbelievable